my beef with the national divorce crowd  I'm open to that concept but I think  that fundamentally misunderstands the  nature of the radical left they they're  never going to let red States just go  off and do their own thing the left they  they get off on rubbing your nose in it  they get off on lording it over you as  we're seeing now like they they I mean  like just look at the I mean one example  out of many I mean look at  um you know look at the the way that the  the  um you know gay pride movement has  evolved over the past 20 30 40 years you  know it started as you know just you  know do what you want in your own  bedroom to civil unions to gay marriage  to the pride movement to transgender to  grooming children it's about rubbing it  in the faces of their political enemies  and so I just I think that the concept  that we're going to have this uh very  civil National divorce I think that's a  bit nice